[Music]
what does it mean to be playing in the
2019 US Championships this is my I don't
I don't even remember the 9th or 10th
time already I think yeah it means a lot
to still get to keep playing this event
year after year and I think this is the
strongest year I think I've said that
before but it just keeps getting
stronger it's one of the tournaments
that we simply cannot miss all the
strong players are here you know the
world number 2 challenger for bambor was
here so the assembly won't want
determine that they can't say no no big
honors usual and it's also I think the
strongest edition of the u.s.
championship feature keeps getting
stronger so it's great to see that
American chess is improving that every
year becomes more of a challenge to to
play here this year there are five
twenty seven hundredths so you know it's
gonna be a wild tournament for me but
I'm really excited to be able to you
know show show my best against these
players so always a great pleasure for
me to compete in in this just absolutely
a important event it was it was not not
easy to qualify so I'm happy to make in
then there are many very extraordinary
factors that had to happen just for me
to get in this year so I think it's a
blessing first and foremost for me I
want to do or I want to perform better
in the US Championship this year than
last year Lasher is probably my worst
performance overall through all the US
Championships so I'd like to perform
better first and then beyond that
obviously I would like to win the event
but first things first just got off to a
good start and I'm gonna take it from
there
really happy to be back here I missed
the last few years by just a little bit
so it's good to be back and hoping to
play well this is truly wonderful this
is a unique opportunity to come out and
play at the highest level and the
championships been getting stronger and
stronger and it's gotta be one of those
strongest tournaments in the history of
United States HS I'm very privileged be
back for me it's special because it's
the first tournament the first classical
tournaments in in a long time like in
two years so it feels with a strange or
a missing classical chess so I'm very
excited to be here it's it's really
exciting to be back because this year I
think is the strongest u.s. championship
of all of them I played so and there's
some new players as well this year so I
think of the winning the championship
last year was a dream come true for me
it was the proudest moment my life so
far proudly played for America my entire
life and to finally be the country the
champion of the country I loved so
dearly it was the proudest moment of my
life and I'm gonna fight my heart out to
try to do it again
[Music]